[Music]
well thank you very much for that warm
introduction I'm going to be talking
about roasts for JavaScript errs show of
hands who has heard of roasts before
all right cool looks like no one raised
their hands as far as I could tell all
right but first a quick bit about me I'm
Shawn growth coming out of San Francisco
I work at a company called one graph but
I don't really talk about that today
I'll give a little bit of context about
my experience with rust the main project
I shipped in rust was a cross-compiled
arm embedded system and in kind of an
IOT device and so you can imagine that
we have these bits of hardware that
we're shipping out to the edge and we
need to be able to push updates to them
very very reliably and so we had a lot
of performance and a lot of security and
a lot of correctness concerns with this
project
other than that though I used to work a
lot enclosure and clojurescript
these days I mostly spend my time in
reason and rust but I am here today to
sell you on rust and this is serious
business that's actually why I am
dressed so nicely so that you know that
this is serious business but I do have
my button undone at the top so you know
I'm trustworthy I'm kind of a chill
business guy so with that said I've been
practicing my pitch working with rust in
the beginning is like banging your head
against the wall I know we're all
excited about that but I want to set
expectations at the beginning of this
talk it's good to think about rust from
the negatives initially so you're at
least setting expectations basically
anytime you have a bit of JavaScript
code if you write the equivalent in rust
it will be longer it will be more
intricate and we'll have a lot more
symbols it's not always true but it's
just a good attitude to have because
it's true enough of the time now rust
itself is described as a systems level
programming language
that cares about performance security
and correctness I don't know if
systems-level programming is such a good
description for it because it goes in a
lot of interesting destinations well
that's how they describe themselves so
we'll run with it but from a JavaScript
is point of view Russ is interesting
because it's low level very very very
low level but it has a lot of
abstractions and they focus a lot on
zero cost abstractions in particular it
also has guaranteed memory safety which
is a big issue whenever you are working
a lower-level language it also carries a
lot about concurrency so has threads
without data races and it has some nice
things that kind of inherits some of the
like reason type of features like type
inference and pattern matching and has a
very minimal runtime but why would you
care why do you want to have low level
but with abstractions rust is very
focused on very predictable performance
at any given time it's going to give you
as much control as you need to eke out
every bit of performance from your
hardware this includes things like
memory allocation layout garbage
collection all that sort of thing
but once you get access to all of that
power basically you have this amazing
gun that you will immediately point at
your foot and pull the trigger it's very
very difficult to ensure data integrity
whenever you have this level of control
in particular trying to maintain any
sort of data integrity with that level
of control with concurrency is next to
impossible so many of the bugs that we
face in our day to day usage of servers
is because of threads with data races
and type inference type inference is a
topic that's near and dear to my heart
but I would say before we explain what
type inference is for like why not step
back and actually ask what the hell are
types for and if you ask C C says types
are for performance types tell the
compiler for all of your data how should
I
be represented at runtime both in memory
and on the CPU and typescript and flow
they don't care about the delay out of
the data what they care about is
correctness all right if you think about
C it can't prevent many of the mistakes
that you might have or where you pass
one string when you should have passed
an array I mean as long as they look
like bytes it's fine and typescript you
can add as many types as you want but it
will never be used by v8 whenever you're
actually running your code so you kind
of have these two different values that
Tice might offer and different languages
will choose different pieces of it and
Russ says that well types are for
correctness and for performance why not
do both and there is another language
that has said this before Java
I know Java is not very popular and if
you look at Java right here so this is
an example of declaring some variables
in Java and you say hey I have an
integer called number and it's 29 and I
feel like this is like working with a
compiler that's very hard of hearing
right because I say hey my flag is false
and you should know that it's a boolean
right what else could it be I told you
it's false but the compiler is like I'm
sorry didn't hear you and so you have to
kind of shout that's hey this is a
boolean and you have to repeat yourself
a lot so the idea is type inference
actually says what if the compiler were
to look through your code and say can I
figure out the types for you so in this
case I'm declaring a variable called
elam and it's gonna be an element inside
of my array and it's just five the u8 is
a literal for an unsigned 8-bit integer
you don't have to have it but it's nice
if you want to have it and you see that
I'm going to create a vector which is
basically an array but I don't say what
the vector is off I just say hey it's a
vector and now whenever I push the
element in to the vector Russ knows this
must be a vector of unsigned 8-bit
integers and the cool thing is that we
have very very minimal type annotations
that a programmer has to do
but the compiler is still happy right
the compiler can check for all sorts of
bugs and it can optimize the exact
memory layout of your code as much as
you need and so the compiler is happy
and the programmer is happy and it's
kind of this principle in Ross where
wherever possible the computer should be
doing work for us rather than us doing
work for the computer now why is a
minimal runtime so important right so
traditionally with things like C or C++
you're kind of targeting beefy machines
right you're pushing to Linux somewhere
and it has gigabytes of hard drive and
gigabytes of RAM and it doesn't matter
how big it is right because you'll
download it once and it's fine but as we
start to push to smaller devices or to
the web in particular that puts a lot of
pressure on how much data you can
actually ship to your clients
so go is another language that has been
working really hard at having really
great web assembly support the challenge
is go was originally designed to run on
servers where space and size are not a
concern we care much more about
performance than we do about size and so
what that meant is that go has kind of
built this culture where by default a
hello world go application compiled to
web assembly we'll start at two
megabytes and if you pull in any library
it's going to balloon to about 10
megabytes very very quickly and I'll
give the credit there's work on a thing
called tiny go which is a subset of go
that starts at 10 kilobytes which is
amazing but the challenge here is
libraries actually have to add support
for tiny go because the ecosystem has
built up with this expectation that well
having a big runtime is not a problem
but rust was originally designed to go
everywhere including embedded devices
that are so small they can't actually
fit Lib C so you can write a rust
program that will compile with no
standard library do you have to bring
your own but that gives you the ability
to define exactly the size and
performance characteristics of your
application
and like I said it rust inherits a lot
from the ML language of family so like
Haskell or Oh camel or a reason in
particular pattern matching
so pattern matching is near and dear to
my heart so you can see here that I have
a list of greetings so there were three
of them and what I'm gonna do is iterate
over them and I'm going to get the index
and the item and now I'm just gonna have
a switch here basically match I'm going
to say based off of this index I want to
print out a different greeting so if
it's zero uh printed English outs Korean
or Swedish and this right here is not
too bad right we can look at like the
list of 1 through zero through one two
and we can see that yes there are three
greetings there but what happens when
there is a third one right now we can
verify it but what if these two bits of
data were actually a part in the code
base then what will happen is this will
crash so what happens is russ has
exhaustive pattern matching where it
says I have detected a case that you
have not handled and in fact I will not
compile this because it is guaranteed to
crash if this case happens and you can
see here that it's giving me this nice
error message the error messages in Russ
are heavily inspired by those in elm so
it's a systems level programming
language that really cares about
developer experience you can see that
hey you didn't cover this underscore
case which is kind of a weird thing to
say what it's saying is I looked at what
you're mapping over you're mapping over
numbers it's really hard for you in one
source code file to list every single
number possible so you need to have a
default case which is this underscore so
it's literally telling you hey you need
to add support for this default case if
it was something else like say an enum
that had maybe open or closed or some
finite number of states it would have
said hey you have open but not closed
you should handle that case and the cool
thing is they canonicalize all of their
errors so you can see here if you want
to know more
information about that you can just say
hey rust explain to me why why is it so
important why are you bothering me about
this and we'll actually print out
documentation in your terminal or your
editor saying hey here's a list of all
the things that could go wrong that I'm
watching out for you right now with this
error so we add a default case and Russ
is happy and we're happy because we know
that this is never ever going to crash
so from the correctness point of view I
would say debugging sucks there is never
a time that I'm excited about debugging
unless it is so bad that I'm like oh man
when I go to the pub tonight and I tell
people about this oh it's gonna make for
a great story but most of the time I
don't want to be debugging so I say
there are three questions from order of
easiest to hardest about debugging the
easiest is who should be doing the
debugging second is when enter is where
so who should do it well this is easy
the language by virtue of construction
the language should make it so that it
is impossible for me to add bugs into my
program wherever that's not possible
because the language needs to give me
more power that might introduce bugs the
compiler should start checking my code
right the compiler has access to all of
my code it has access to all of my
dependencies it should be checking
through everything that the language
couldn't to make sure that I didn't add
any bugs and then maybe some automated
tooling around like linters maybe this
is something that my company has about
some rules about how I should be coding
finally there are tests if all of that
fails and I'm I have to still debug then
I guess it's me but if a developer
doesn't do it then the user does it and
that's the worst scenario right how many
times have we been on a plane or train
booking web site and you go to submit
the form and it doesn't work and so you
open up the console you get the HTML
element and you manually submit it in
the console and it works right so that
it's possible for the user to debug and
maybe that's a good thing but it's
certainly not a great experience
and so the question next question is
then when should debugging happen and
like Elm Russ says it should happen
upfront you should push all of that up
front because the moment that you
introduce that bug is the moment when
you had the most context to fix it so
it's going to list out all of the bugs
that you have it in a given time and say
fix these before I compile and that
means that by the time you actually get
it to compile it just works most of the
time it's actually a very jarring
experience especially coming from
something like JavaScript which is
amazingly flexible and a lot of fun to
program in but it will allow you to make
mistakes that will take you a long time
to track down and I want to give one
last shout out to the Russ community
here because they have built a crazy
empathetic and welcoming community most
systems programming languages the
community is not known for being very
welcoming but this community cares
hugely about the experience of new
developers and experienced developers so
much so that they regularly have surveys
about the experience of different parts
of rust and then they will actually take
the top pains and form a working group
so they knew that web assembly was going
to be a really important task for them
so they actually formed a working group
to say your job is to make it so that
someone who doesn't know rust can come
to this website read through the docs
and have a fully working Game of Life in
30 minutes which is an insane task but
it is they've done it so now why would
you care as a JavaScript er and it's
because russ now actually compiles down
to web assembly and web assembly is
pretty crazy powerful it is
I think unprecedented and how well
designed it is and how adopted it is
usually a lot of great technology kind
of never gets adopted I want to give
another caveat here though
using webassembly from javascript is
currently a little bit on the idiomatic
it feels a little bit weird but it's not
too bad but that also means that because
rust is compiling to web assembly that
also be a little bit thankful but in
particular rust is compiling down to
JavaScript or sorry into web assembly
and webassembly literally is just a big
array of bytes ones and zeros there are
no strings there are no floats there are
just ones and zeros and all the things
that we take for granted in JavaScript
don't really exist there and yet we want
javascript to be able to call functions
and pass in data and retrieve data more
than just maybe ones and zeroes so what
we need to do is figure out how to
interrupt between these two systems by
default your JavaScript will load up it
will reach out and download a big blob
of wasum data it will instantiate it and
pass in all of the functions from the
outside world that the web assembly
bundle is allowed to know about and then
having instantiated it it can now call
into functions that exist on the web
assembly side so you can imagine here
that I have my wasm and I call greet and
I pass in hi that's going to go over to
the web assembly side I've implemented a
greet function there and I'm going to
return a string back but this bridge
right here going back and forth has to
be implemented by me and when I'm
implementing it I have a couple of
different goals one is I want to
minimize the copying because these are
two separate worlds they both have their
own view of memory there a memory does
not touch one another and so that means
if I were in JavaScript and I just
copied a bunch of memory and sent it
over to the other side that would
actually be really slow it would put a
lot of pressure on the garbage
collection and it would kind of in many
ways like defeat the points of using
rust which is I want to have
fine-grained control over memory
allocation and performance so what we're
gonna do instead is on the web assembly
side and rust where
going to create a huge array of memory
and now on JavaScript we're going to
actually just call a function like hey
rust can you create the game world for
me and this will initiate all of the or
initialize all of the data structures
the world the players etc and then it
will just pass back pointers to
JavaScript side and these are very very
small and now javascript is going to
just call functions using these pointers
and rust will update everything and then
javascript will be able to just reach
into the memory and see the result and
this is nice because javascript has so
many things that we take for granted
right access to dom garbage collection
like you have objects objects are cool
you have arrays and strings like things
that you don't feel are very special but
whenever you don't have them you you
really miss them whereas on rust you
have all this nice performance and
memory management but you don't really
have objects you have like structs and
you have arrays and vectors and you have
two kinds of strings for whatever reason
rust people say they don't I always say
they do so what we're gonna do is have
this shared memory between them
javascript will call into rust rust will
update the memory and then javascript
can read the memory so we have this nice
cycle flowing a bit like react maybe and
that means that we can make sure that we
only pass small bits of data between the
JavaScript and rough slide and
everything is able to actually kind of
exist inside of the un8 arrays but that
we still have to on the JavaScript side
even though we can read all those bytes
it's still unpleasant we have to figure
out how to construct strings and
boolean's and whatnot from them but the
rust people are aware of this and they
have built phenomenal developer
experience so what I've done here this
is the game of life written in rust I
have a cell which is an enum a cell in
the game of life can either be dead or
it can be alive and I'm saying hey rust
I want you to represent this as a zero
and I want you to
this is a one the rest of the world
should know but I care about how that's
actually implemented in memory because I
need that for performance or whatever
now every tick that gets called from
JavaScript I'm going to iterate through
the entire board and I'm going to get a
list of all the neighbors around the
cell and now I'm gonna match and you can
see this pattern matching again where
I'm matching off of two items which is
really cool and I can say hey if this
cell is alive and the number of
neighbors is less than two then the cell
should be dead and so on and so forth
so in this one line right here or this
one chunk
I can concisely encode all of the rules
of the game of life
it'll be type checked and will be
immaculately out in memory now what Russ
is going to do as part of this as an
automatic part whenever they generates
the webassembly code it will also
generate an NPM package so that you on
the JavaScript side will be able to pull
in all of those functions and call them
but not only that remember that rust is
statically typed it has intimate
knowledge of all of the types in your
application so it will also generate
typescript bindings but not type script
bindings like I would writes where it's
like oh it's any I'll come back and fix
this later it writes them as though I
were a really good programmer so now we
can come in here and let's take a look
at what this actually looks like with a
real application so this is there's a
component library or there's a library
called you and you as inspired by Elm
except that what it's going to do is you
will have a JSX like syntax you'll have
service workers that will get spun up in
the background automatically to handle
concurrency and Russ is going to
guarantee that you have data integrity
no race conditions all throughout the
entire experience so you just write a
normal rust application you compile it
out and you can get all of these
benefits so this is what it looks like
to write a component using you so you
can see I have this HTML with a bang
this bang is really cool bang means
this is a macro it's like a babble
transform but it's built into the
language so any library author can ship
a JSX type of thing as part of their
library they can bring the language into
their domain and make it much more
accessible and so this library has
actually implemented their own HTML
macro and all of these props here are
actually tight so if you pass in the
wrong type or you have the wrong
children it won't compile so this is
like an amazing experience to actually
write HTML inside of this low-level
language and have everything typed and
compiled out nicely but then we have
maybe events so imagine I have my in my
core loop of my application I have a
request
so I'm gonna send this off to the
service workers or they can send it to
me and the response to it should come
back as a answer what I'm gonna do is
whenever I receive a signal I'm gonna
match over that and say hey if the
signal was a question then pull out the
body and then send an answer to this
saying hey that's cool and what this is
going to do is this won't compile
because the message might also be a
response and also if I add for example
maybe I have a question right now but
maybe I want to add a demand later then
if I add that in everywhere that
reference is that will break and I will
be able to go through and fix everything
once compile it out and it will just
work now this is what it looks like if
you're actually consuming the generated
rust from JavaScript so right here this
import memory this is the big bit of
memory that we talked about that the
rusts compiler generated for us so we're
gonna pull that in and then we're going
to initialize it it's just a big array
of bytes we don't really care but from
then on we're gonna say hey get the sell
at this index and if that cell is dead
then I want you to draw a dead color or
else use the alive color and the thing I
love here is this
is actually the enum that we defined in
rust so we don't care if it was 0 or 1
or true or false or a or B doesn't
matter we get to code as though someone
were a really good programmer on the
other side and they gave us this really
good API and that's all generated based
off of the deep knowledge that rust has
about your program I'll give a quick
aside about the syntax I mentioned
before that you know rust is a bit more
verbose but it is also very heavy with
symbols so just be prepared but the nice
thing is they care so much about
developer experience and onboarding that
the error messages will oftentimes
navigate you out so for example here I
have foo it takes a B which I said is
immutable unsigned 64-bit value and
being very specific about what I want
here and it's like hey you are trying to
borrow a mutable value you can't do that
maybe you should try just removing the
an mutable and what happens is it guides
you out of this problem enough times
that you start to develop kind of a
muscle memory about what is this symbol
actually doing so I want to give one
demo of what this actually looks like so
this is an NES emulator written in rust
and it is super fast super cool if we
open up the developer tools and we take
a profile you can see that the animation
or sorry each of these frames is tiny
it's incredibly performance it's very
good on my battery it's in fact been
running in the background for quite a
while and my battery is still doing fine
but the cool thing is with Russ you can
also compile out that same application
to a native application so this is it
running using SDL instead of web geo and
this is super mario brothers using the
same code that's type checked and you
can run this on a desktop or a mobile or
you can compile to the web as we saw
with the other example
and then there are some pretty other
crazy things that are happening so in
particular this idea of webassembly
like I said is crazy well-designed and
someone has actually implemented a web
assembly to rust compiler so kind of
like a D compiler and someone actually
there's a subset of typescript called
assembly script which is how a type
scrip people go to web assembly it's
kind of the non allocating subset of
typescript and someone wrote a really
cool Gameboy emulator in that and they
compile it out to webassembly fast and
cool but then someone took the web
assembly to Rusty compiler turn that
into rust and then they took the Russ
code and compile it out to a native
application so it's kind of a crazy
pipeline but like the future seems very
exciting I'm going to end on this note
that I think that we are actually rust
and webassembly represent a
unprecedented opportunity in our
industry because our industry only moves
forward via secretion if there is any
abstraction or any implementation that
is even a little bit successful it never
dies
to that point I have a terminal in my
computer a terminal is a end point like
a keyboard that talks to a mainframe
right and my terminal understands crazy
old Escape codes but that can never go
away we are stuck with it forever and
we're also stuck with like Lib C and
Lipsy has caused unprecedented amount of
good but also tons of security issues it
has been very difficult to actually ship
anything reliably with it and
webassembly and rusts mean that we
actually have a platform that it's not
it's not in our best interest to ship
all of Linux all of Lib C to the browser
we need to have a new smaller
implementation of these things and maybe
we can do it in a safe language that's
also fast and also correct and that
could be rust and I actually think that
in the next five to ten years most of
the JavaScript that we run will be
written in rust I don't think most
people will write rust but I think that
most of the code we run will be like who
will actually write it it's the people
who really want fine-grain performance
control and the people who want safety
security and correctness guarantees and
this is largely library authors right
how like to what extent does the react
authors or view or angular have to go
through to eke out all the performance
and correctness and so they're under
tremendous pressures to actually do this
and they need tooling that helps them
and I think that's likely rust and
actually think that web assembly and
rust will also end up going to node
where you can actually pull in all of
these implementations of great rust
libraries they're already compiled out
to web assembly and it will just work
inside of node no more libsass compiling
c++ nightmare so here's my closing pitch
working with rusts at least in the
beginning is like banging your head
against the wall but at a very slight
angle so that every time you hit the
wall you actually make a little bit of
progress and at the end you actually
look back at this blood-stained wall and
you're kind of happy because you built a
thing that you didn't think was possible
all right here are some links but
otherwise thank you
[Applause]
[Music]